people are going to be outside today
suffering with their allergies because
of the winds oh my goodness now the good
news is as we look out on the west side
winds aren't quite as strong now at west
charleston in the 215 as we watch our
faithful palm tree on top of the red
rock casino resort right there things
look pretty nice but in the interior of
the valley inside town
it has been blowing especially up around
the northeast part of town at nellis
harry reid international we've still
been getting some winds gusts 20
sometimes 30 miles an hour temperatures
mainly in the 60s around the valley this
morning mid 50s out at red rock it's
been breezy to gusty up in the spring
mountains overnight and this morning and
that will continue and we will again
after daybreak get those winds going out
of the north so just most areas are
going to feel those 20 to 25 mile an
hour winds and stronger winds along the
colorado river valley still some gusty
winds to 30 miles an hour right now
those could be 40 plus for laughlin
bullhead city boulder city even out to
lake mead looking for those strong gusts
as well 56 in mesquite right now low 60s
in boulder city 59 in pahrump 53 at
indian springs but look at those chilly
temperatures up in northern western
nevada and ely white pine counties 19
this morning with 30s in caliani lincoln
county tone upon reno in the 30s a 40
mile an hour wind gusts for north las
vegas harry reid international very
close to 40 for nellis and boulder city
right behind you and that's all because
of that cold front and north winds
associated with that front so the
southwest will stay clear for la phoenix
today if you're traveling looks like
things will be fine except a little uh
breezy to windy and then look at the
snow across the upper midwest the great
lakes still winter hangs on with a
vengeance and the southeast again trying
to recover from that severe weather more
than two dozen twisters from the deep
south
louisiana all the way over to georgia in
the carolinas yesterday they could see
those thunderstorms reforming today so
today we get clear skies but wind
advisories and fire weather warnings
along the colorado river valley that's
10 a.m to 7 p.m a dry
air low humidity gusty winds not a good
combination for fire weather danger and
80 degrees today that's a 10 degree drop
from yesterday lighter winds tomorrow
and then we ramp right back up to 90s
friday and saturday but another really
cold late system late season storm will
bring us more wind and cool us off to
the 70s early next week